[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have a bad feeling about this
find out what the [ __ ] I'm doing this
weeks we believe me you do not love
losing you lost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a blog I have no idea if the team
was be rolling today I feel like they
weren't but I was in the office all day
client [ __ ] day after Kobe's passing
just gloomy just like [ __ ] [ __ ]
the wind knocked out of you so I hope
everybody had a good day I know it was
tough for a lot of people and hopefully
the team will feel more tomorrow we are
back alright so right now work were
checking the lighting the rock we have a
little concept for Gary for an IG post
so he's about a head out of the office
in about five to ten minutes we're
hoping to grab him on the way out take a
picture like this edit it a little bit
and then throw it up so good yep waiting
outside the room I don't know why
exactly we're waiting outside the room I
know I'm late I thought the room I don't
know why Jon's waiting outside the room
yeah getting a couple of documents
signed over here and you know it's
another day 6:30 on a Monday long week
ahead feels like a week or any went by
we're gonna there's no oh oh oh alright
here comes the man come on you're honest
you're running in a photograph of you
being blind no right no right in the
company you hate to see it and that's
why we well a man's gotta go that's a
one for Lou and John and zero for d-roc
right that's good though
look at respect it that's first and it's
pretty standard honestly usually it
takes a couple tries do your accent most
annoying person on the team so usually
he gets at first failed today though
unfortunately well we'll get on tomorrow
is he here - Mike is he here tomorrow is
he here tomorrow we're in tomorrow and
then we have another one coming tomorrow
that we're cooking solo right yeah yes
you stay tuned to stay tuned hey guys
Justin I'm the influencer side of team
Gary you guys are about to meet Gavin
he's a influencer phenom 12 year old kid
that started when he was 9 you got to
see one of his first videos on YouTube
he was doing some puppets so you gotta
check it out now he's blown up to 1.3
million on was it tick tock
he's going crazy so take a look at the
interview and have a good time is there
anything I can help you with well what I
kind of wanted to talk to you about what
social medias like one thing that I want
to you know hate yes talk about how you
deal with hate I'm happy to talk about
it sometimes you know there's times
where it can really get of course and
especially at this age look here's what
I've here's what I did when I was in
school when it wasn't an audience it was
just like kids in school and it's
definitely what I've done over the last
15 years I actually think you need to
think about being sympathetic to the
person that's leaving the comment like
what I always tell everybody is like
think about how sad a human has to be to
watch something of yours and then leave
something so that they could drag you
down to their pain so I don't get mad at
people especially because they don't
know me
I actually feel bad for them and there's
something that happens when you start
looking at hey you're not as cute as you
think you are you're not a good singer
like wait till you grow up you're gonna
be a drug addict like whatever they
write if you actually see that from the
perspective like man I'm so grateful
that I'm happy and doing what I like and
this person like I always picture them
and it's not like some weird guy in a
basement it's just like a human that's
living their life and they're they're
stuck in a bad place and the only new
thing they know how to do in that moment
is to try to drag somebody else at it
because they're envious or jealous and
those are only out of them being unhappy
you're not envious and jealous when
you're happy yeah
like when I see you winning or somebody
else winning I get pumped because I
think the world is abundant braum I'm
really serious with you right now
you have to feel bad for them and the
second that becomes the way you practice
it because if you're accepting it that
means you have that only that means
you're taking on that insecurity that's
you when somebody's [ __ ] on you
that's you speaking to yourself about
your insecurities and we all have them
at your age but like I promise you brow
you should be very grateful about you're
not on the other side of that comment
and it doesn't mean I don't hear them or
[ __ ] them like everyone's like [ __ ]
haters or eat [ __ ] rolls
mmm-hmm I'm actually the worse I'm
sympathetic to it I love the people that
hate me because I wished them more
happiness
hey vlog it's Katie I informs the
influencers for mr. Gary Vaynerchuk if
you follow me this way I'll show you
it's by my desk first things first
hydration station um it's it's marked by
the times so that I'm always drinking
water because you spend long days here
noise cancel headphones block out the
haters we have two monitors because I do
a lot of stuff blue light lenses because
I've got to save the eyes gum cuz I'm
the gum plug on the team you need gum
Zayn got some gum lip balm because we've
got plant Clippers because I got a new
plant
it's a popo's great office place um we
have some stickers because anti-bully
kindness club over here initiation
tonight 7:00 p.m. we have this because
we were sent this and zero points are
given Oh May and I like to play force uh
what is this
not Foursquare Kinect for when we need a
little mental break you know also forgot
to show you this Polaroid of the
D'Amelio family ay-ay-ay
tick tock stars so yeah that's my desk
created it out of a 10 now back to the
vlog can I ask Dana if you're filming
today I would highly recommend that you
work with the admins right now and try
to interview the people that I had
meetings with today to see what they
thought about the meeting and if they
don't up they're not interested no
pressure like literally blast Lou Lou
can you email right now with Daniel on
it like hey we're doing something for
Gary's vlog of like interviewing people
who are in meetings with Gary today
about how the meeting went and in caps
no pressure but if you're interested let
us know we wanted to do right now that's
what I want to do let the rest of team
know I want to be role everything and
then if you can't film the meaning but
the person's willing to [ __ ] talk
about it then it's what the drive-up
think what does Meg think what did she
really think and no pressure caps
everybody I've met with today nothing to
be really [ __ ] cool I should mail
hey I'll do it in 30 seconds you can go
in I'm just gonna feel some real quick
so friends just sit here you're playing
poker here we're not actually playing
okay I'm gonna get a wide shot right now
I'm gonna come back hurry
not an easy victory for the g-man Kenya
for the vlog one of the most iconic
moments of my life is Brandon slept over
my house in 1992 before a card show
Brandon didn't like a football didn't
play Madden but like and we played
Madden on Genesis and the first game I
beat I beat him bad and I think the
second game or maybe not even maybe not
even maybe that's just me trying to make
myself feel better
here's the punch line he used the Bears
cuz he was a Cubs fan so he used the
Bears so for Chicago
we played Bennett and he beat me when I
tell you what happened next is all time
it was like 1:00 in the morning and we
had a card show like 7:00 I wouldn't let
him go to sleep because we had a play
again and I beat him like 72 nothing cuz
he wasn't trying cuz what his move was
I'm gonna not play but I refused to let
that move work and just kept beating the
[ __ ] and if him making pretend that he
was trying it is literally still one of
our favorite stories but the best part
was he actually had a brilliant counter
move which is like that I'm not gonna
try which takes up the spirit but I was
so insane I was like [ __ ] it I'm just
gonna make your tiny strike step you do
another [ __ ]
alright let's do this
no dude I don't own this game I own the
Minnesota franchise of this game in the
league find out on this daily be right
do it again
weekly be good here we go snoop chanel
Perez I'm a copywriter here at
vaynermedia and this is actually my last
week at the office my last day is on
Friday I've been here for almost six
years five years now so my meeting with
Gary was essentially my farewell meeting
my goodbyes how was that for you it was
great Gary is a phenomenal leader and
I'm actually pretty sad to not be
working under him anymore since I've
been here so long he's kind of just like
helped me navigate a lot of tricky
things with my career and he's always
been very supportive of me and
originally when I went into that meeting
I thought I was gonna be like hey I'm so
grateful for everything you've done and
of course you kind of like flip the
script and used it to encourage me and
tell me how much I've grown and how
excited he is to see me proceed in my
career so and I don't know how much you
guys be of Gary but he's just like such
a genuine leader and that's something
you don't come across often because he's
so sharp but he's got such a soft heart
and like I think a lot of people see the
like content side of him that's like
super rough and hard and rock but he has
this ability like when you get
one-on-one with him he like really
sincerely cares about what you're going
through so I've learned a lot from him
and you know I hope to bring that to my
next job
[Music]
so the party that I sent my cousin to
that one he didn't know how to manage it
well it broke down so how do you manage
you know you can't be enthused to spots
at the same time so how do you manage to
deal with a lot of things at once by
knowing it might happen expect the worse
by being mentally ok if it happens it's
not the fact that you know make sense if
your cousin didn't know how to do it it
makes sense that that could happen so by
having zero things that most people do
not mad at the cousin not mad at the
situation just go directly into
solutions so he solutions for me every
day I mean even right now like I got a
real thing right this is actually metas
[ __ ] I got a real thing I got a dress
like you know next thing pops up my cam
like [ __ ] these guys like literally like
real life like this is not the most
important [ __ ] right but so grateful
for the barter we did I'm super zeroed
in to you right now and like we're gonna
wrap up in like a minute or two take
this [ __ ] iconic photo I hope it gives
you a [ __ ] load of business we'll make
sure to use this if I can put them right
in here right now if it leads to
unlimited photo boots for you for
everyone watches the blog and then
literally like get on the phone and try
to fix this situation the way you handle
being in multiple places is being
prepared to know that when multiple
places are in the mix that at any moment
you're gonna get 9-1-1 once you go there
and you realize it's when you call that
place and be like and they're yelling
you like you [ __ ] this and [ __ ] you
and all that right right like like where
I go is I'm like listen Rick listen
Sally like you're 100% right like the
machine broke like I really apologize
like let me let's let's take a step back
how can I make this better
and Rick's like give me all my money
back you make a decision there's been
times where I said yes there's been
times where I said listen I I don't want
to [ __ ] you Rick I will consider it
but let's get coffee tomorrow I don't
want your [ __ ] coffee I want my money
back good now you're gonna make another
decision now you're like all right I'm
really my business - I want this
reputation do I just take this out the
amount of [ __ ] micro elves I've taken
in my life to get to Who I am now
sometimes you can't afford that money
giving it back sometimes you actually
have to fight with the customer because
if you don't get it it's completely over
did you get a deposit didn't you if you
didn't get a deposit he's like [ __ ] you
you might not even get it in a place to
sit like the amount of [ __ ] times I'm
gonna bail I didn't know [ __ ] [ __ ]
learned in the dirt losing winning
didn't teach me [ __ ] it confuses you
when you win it's tricks because you
didn't learn you just think you're great
it's losing that's the [ __ ] game the
battle scars are attractive
[Music]
there's a lot of cutting hairs if you're
in New York you need to see this man
headed to Charlotte for a board meeting
I joined the board of Bojangles a
wonderful QoS our company competes in
the chicken space heading to the office
gonna do GMA Talk Super Bowl commercials
so keeping busy Bloggie
and I go can I call you guys Bobby yo
well this is yesterday's wine sex was
like the first clunker in months I think
it's a hundred percent because we wrote
it yeah what's what's greater than a
hundred percent there's a wine of the
decade I give him a lot of credit I love
James the wine of the decade is a Super
Tuscan
what's greater I wish he gave it a
hundred and one that would have just
broke everybody you know what's funny I
feel like if I rated a wine 101 and be
similar to when I invented second round
picks in our fantasy league in the
middle of the season I think I need to
taste like a thousand wines find the
best wine ever and raving 101 and just
watch the entire wine world people
forever brother before the email
newsletter
I created a fax newsletter and would fax
people offers of wine and the list got
so big yeah I got to talk about this
more but the list got sodas right I'm
such a [ __ ] idiot this is why thank
God we have weekly V now this with it
nobody knows this I don't think I've
ever said it I faxed so many people that
the list got so big and they was so slow
that well even when I would send the
fact of 2 p.m.
some people were getting it at 2:00 in
the morning and some people cuz this was
at the height of fax pre-dinner email
like right on the cusp obviously people
had fax in their home offices so we
would get phone calls my [ __ ] [ __ ]
you sent me a fax of 140 and the more
facts are loud as [ __ ] I'm a man like
people like kids are crying at midnight
and [ __ ] they're like I don't want
your [ __ ] peanut or your [ __ ]
waking up Sally you know imma wait I'm
like 18 bro I'm underrated I haven't
even had people think like I haven't
started telling my stories hey guys it's
Jason I'm the editor of the first few
episodes of weekly
the next meeting here about to watch is
a little behind the scenes of the last
episode that I had to make it was like
36 hours of footage and I was in a
dilemma if we should show every meeting
that Gary was having or dressed the hot
moments so then this is me going in
there and acting Gary on his feedback
check it out
we want to showcase every one of your
day because that's what you've been
saying b-roll everything you all I think
throw key over it or just show that hot
awesome moment and then roll it to the
next day so Houston my my thought is
there's a model to be had where you guys
do both where where the moments of the
day I actually think you can show five
and a half hours of my day in 15 seconds
and maybe I'm wrong like I'm looking at
you go for her but but like to me it's
like two seconds and writing over it
meeting with answer like like like like
I'm just curious
I've always been curious of that look I
always think about it as like the way
you guys edit where it's like you know
there's like it's like a long string and
it's like like that's kind of how I
think about it's like 13th like four and
a half minutes of the epic thing and
then it's like like just literally three
seconds of like 17 different rooms I was
in and that becomes you know I don't
know 51 seconds it's good math at home
kids
math was I don't make a blog and then
you be like great news yeah we're gonna
make these for a long time I don't give
a [ __ ] what you do make a silent film
for this one I'll give a [ __ ] so I
thought that was really cool meeting
with Gary it showed kind of his creative
freedom that he gives us and how he
values the marathon of the documentation
of these vlogs rather than every single
episode being perfect
it was obviously better on me while I'm
editing these two you know reduce the
pressure it's just it's cool having a
leader that just values the creative
freedom also if you guys have any
feedback leave it in the comments I want
to hear it you guys have to say how we
show Gary's life and now I'm at the blog
[Music]
board meeting dinner with the board
tonight
board meeting tomorrow off to Miami for
Superbowl bunch of events Boehner sports
party Mike event for 137 p.m. with D
Wade and and networking and making
[ __ ] [ __ ] happen it's always good to
be where everybody is because that's
shaken habit 750 [ __ ]
what's up blog I just got done with the
CMO some jingles we just had a little
glass of wine
Cena's epic all about to go into the
board meeting dinner at the board
meeting tomorrow headed to Miami and a
bunch of phone calls about our Super
Bowl spots we got three of them by the
time you watch this they they're magic
there's some here's some headlines or
clips about them team and that in keep
it rolling yeah that's good
just decline calls had a call
oh no sorry hey everybody I'm maja I
work with Gary on Team Gary Vee my role
basically is to help create
relationships for Gary in the US and
globally so people know what Gary's up
to what the company is doing and how do
we do storytelling on a global scale
so we went to Miami we had a great time
we went to radio room basically all of
the press are there and you're
speed-dating you're talking to all the
media telling your stories we had three
monster Superbowl ads this year so we
took the time to get on all the radio
stations and TV networks to talk about
all things Super Bowl brands underpriced
attention why companies should think
about doing advertising the Super Bowl
and where we think marketing and Super
Bowl mix so it was super fun a really
cool vibe can't wait for you guys to
check it out check out the blog
listening
[Music]
[Applause]
how you feeling prepping just like focus
man I know exactly who you are bro
I know exactly we both you know the best
part of all this is I don't even reach
out to guys like you know there's so
many of you in the schema thing where
like when we go into like I'm already
working on next year when you look at a
thousand and you get it down to 50
before you even reach out and then you
start really digging into this is it
there is nothing else for me like all of
you can run forties
all of you can bench the variable is
this they keep doing it man it's great
to see you
great to see you man I'm looking for
your brother I can't wait see here thank
ya
those are two kids at Vayner Sports was
recruited and we didn't get either and I
think actually good job d-roc because if
you look at that interaction you might
think they're like my best friends and
actually they've delivered disappointing
news to us but that doesn't take away
the humanity like I talk a lot about
like on the field like at the time when
they went with somebody I was like like
literally to that you know [ __ ] idiot
like doesn't get like but but that's
like that's the same way of like losing
the game and then you're pissed but then
like when it's over you're shaking hands
like those are wonderful kids it's the
reason we were super focused on trying
to get them so that was a good job you
rock for me to explain that because I
think if you I think if you play it
whether you look at the interaction and
now I give you the Recology don't wait
it shows the class maybe that's the
right you know I'm thinking myself as a
classic but like it's just a class and
like even though what the situation
doesn't work out the way you wanted it
to I'm rooting for those young men they
play a brutal [ __ ] thing like you
know like it's a tough like three star
debater sports is tough that's a tough
gig like they may only be in the league
for two or three years like it's it's
tough out there and so I want those kids
to win after we take a couple of these
go through the sides here you're hot
takes yep remember that great sound good
great the first off sure Gary Vaynerchuk
Gary Vee to silent these were the worst
branding moves of all time you know what
I need a burner handle i I can do some
real damage with a burner you know what
I don't have a burner handle but I
decided right here on this Super Bowl
weekend at the Twitter bar that I'm
creating one and it's gonna do huge
[ __ ] damage and I let the curse on the
Twitter bar huge [ __ ] damage look for
my burner account in 2020 okay
oh this is a good one what was your
first screen name
oh are you talking just in general in
life yeah my first screen name was Jean
Utz
not necessarily the thing I'm most proud
about but if you know like music culture
you'd understand a little bit more it's
not as gross as it sounds but I had many
variations of gee nuts by the way
there's like GE and UTS then there was
one that I used I think on yahoo
messenger with a Z for the nuts part of
it you know that's we kept it kind of
hardcore in 1999 do the favorite wrong I
watch a lot of rom-coms you know crazy
rich Asians like completely like stole
my heart like just like a perfect story
oh what's that Patrick Dempsey can't buy
me love is that the 1980s Patrick
Dempsey like that is an all-time one for
me so Kip I'm fairly solid with rom-coms
those two standout them two minutes left
in the game
we're down six and driving what am I
telling you to you two minutes left
we're down six and driving what do I
tell the team you know it's funny I tend
to use humor to take pressure off of the
situation so I and I like to razz my
favorite person so I'd probably look at
one of the really fat offensive linemen
and I'd probably say something like hey
after we win this [ __ ] Super Bowl can
you please lose 15 pounds you [ __ ] and
then everybody would laugh and we'd go
score and win the Super Bowl okay we
need your take on these sides okay can
you just hit them and then you thought
you you throw them it you can you can
you throw the name at me and I can go an
even quicker overpriced culture
underrated pop star deep deep creativity
all-time legend
but delicious as [ __ ] liquorice
delicious as [ __ ]
black the one of the three things ever
that I didn't like the first time I
tasted it but in my quest to like every
single thing to consume I fought and it
went from tasting like soap to now being
something that I can actually consume
get stuck in my teeth yet I continue to
persevere because it's delicious yeah
overrated wildly overrated Taylor Swift
unbelievably underrated in the way that
she built her personal brand
confusing even like if you think about
how fast I answered everything else I'm
not sure if I love them or hate them the
answer is obviously both I'm a huge
eggnog consumer I actually think the way
that we have bartenders and sommeliers I
think somebody should emerge in culture
as like the eggnog expert and every year
in mid-december
we're all waiting for her or him to put
out their mini dock on the 13 vest
eggnogs of 2020 baby Yoda is a
phenomenal phenomenal job by two people
the creators of it and then the culture
of internet culture to take it and
elevate it
a ton so until it got to high school or
he actually had to be able to play and I
was like I'm not joining the football
team but nerf football and in high
school everybody who wasn't on the
football team we started an after school
football game called the grub ball cuz
we were grubby which was the slang term
for we suck it got so popular this is
real North southern high school in
1993-1994 our side football game that we
played above the hill overlooking
football practice and a football field
called grub ball got so popular that
legitimately people on the football team
went football quit the football team to
join the grub ball game
why are you doing thank you I appreciate
it thank you for having me I love
Twitter to rock I also love this blog I
love you [ __ ] favorite dude right
here eat it Andy I got everything on
asaro we should do that all day long
playing on like you guys should come in
every day and do like your 15 takes
on the half ready at the end of the day
like we might have just [ __ ] like
like I'm literally hot - King culture
that was like I'm really good I'm really
good at oh it's just smart it's just a
good piece like like that was a great
piece of content and I know it's intense
its internet it's entertaining I also
like having that was really good I know
dude were you watching did you listen I
feel like you were networking again
we're doing what you're supposed to be
doing yeah she's doing what she's
supposed to do ask your ticket you can
take a note from
[Music]
then I say something from the blog one
of the best gonna use hair this best
thing about the wine techs is that it
comes out at one o'clock every day while
you're sitting at your desk wishing you
were drinking a glass of wine a full
bottle
what about the lack of friction I just
told you these is detail limited Ricci
you literally reply with a number two to
because if you want one if you like one
you gotta have another almost a field
plan gave me a shout out on my podcast
you changed my life G I just can't thank
you enough sir for saying what I can for
right here in this moment admiration
maybe that's okay I'd give to get man
uh-huh any golden nuggets what's kind of
golden nuggets how much
I'm kindness are the two [ __ ] things
that actually matter in life you figure
those two things out everything you want
will happen very productive execution in
radio row her thing I clearly did my
thing I mean just a broad talent tonight
I have a veiner sports party with like
the legends of the NFL tomorrow from
6:00 to 9:00 I'm doing this karaoke
thing with Dwayne Wade I'll say I'll
text you the it's nice to meet you bro
have a good time I'll see you guys there
just had a client meeting potential
client meeting with a very big brand
within the PepsiCo world that we don't
work with so just working working with
Harwood and Mary Kate for about 1:37
p.m. and pure well and that's what's
really cool about doing events like this
like you'll come you'll do radio row for
top of the funnel awareness for the
commercials we're running for our
clients or for bigger sports then you'll
run quickly to a meeting where it's just
like literally no different than a
Tuesday morning meeting fly to Chicago
and have a meeting to meet potential
business but you can get it done in
Super Bowl that's why these big events
are so effective I now run to Bloomberg
talk about on Bloomberg TV Super Bowl
spots like so it's a very dynamic event
like where you're mixing that's what I
love about being or X I mean I bet
somebody already earlier today that we
may book as an exclusive speaker
at Vayner X so there's that obviously
the 1:37 p.m. thing is very much on my
mind big priority in 2020 to get that
you know last year was the Alpha here
this is the beta year so 2021 for me is
like all of you would be signed up and
following 137 p.m. King so that is a lot
on my mind
yeah bro bro [ __ ] up take shirt I need
to give it a sip of the [ __ ] day with
Gary [ __ ] bean all right guys it's a
big thing right now Gary Vaynerchuk good
he's gonna give you tip of the day for
this week I'm Gary tell you everybody
what you guys big of him be [ __ ] kind
it always works
I hear at the Vayner Sports Ray Lewis
legends of NFL party super excited doing
a ton of networking a lot of clients a
lot of fell greats a lot of athletes
just a really solid networking event I
mean this is why you come to the CES in
the South pies and the cans and all this
stuff you get so much done obviously
this gorgeous venue at the Hard Rock lab
of that look at that the guitar the hard
rock guitar right back there just
walking by that guy right there that's
the hard rock CMO so just making [ __ ]
happen like we like to do you know
putting yourself in a position for
serendipity to happen matters long
before an event like this where
everybody's coming up to me I used to go
to these things in tech and in wine
where nobody knew the [ __ ] I was just
say hello hello you know just that [ __ ]
and and having the humility and the
patience for them to walk by and not
give a [ __ ] not give a [ __ ] because I
knew what the sport was gonna be when
you know what the score is gonna be
you're not worried about what the crowd
say and so that's how I live it and it's
still happening right now
please understand it's still happening
right now I'm just getting [ __ ]
started 99% don't know I do
Ajay's are the 1% that knows I'm just
telling them the 99% don't really
understand what's happening with good
intent I'm not trying to hurt feelings
I'm trying to get people to win the
world's abundant I'm I'm gonna eat
regardless but there's so much other
[ __ ] we're talking about meals out
here in abundance I just want people to
eat I ain't I'm gonna continue he's like
he's like you shoot it straight I'm like
with good intent cuz I want you and on
some real [ __ ] get that happiness that
money's gonna be you you been happy they
can get real real real good I got
nothing but friends with money that are
miserable find that happiness with Miami
Fox and Friends through Fox & Friends
7:40 a.m.
I'm a trip on the beach trip where all
the students are shot go talk about the
Super Bowl spots so big day we got GMA
for Monday morning when she ma airing I
know what time you know 10 a.m. don't
hold my hot so that like she didn't
necessarily work directly on that one so
she doesn't know exact time oh she
doesn't she seem like the not a hundred
percent company one of the really cool
things about being at the Super Bowl in
Miami is all the news networks and
television stations sport networks come
and set up their sets live on the beach
so as you guys all know the Super Bowl
was aired on Fox so Fox Sports Fox News
set up a really great set up Gary went
to go film a live interview on Fox &
Friends
we walked in Luke coach Lou Holtz from
Notre Dame was eating barbecue they had
set up a whole segment about what to eat
for the Super Bowl and he was eating
ribs
Gary walked on stage did a great
interview and then the band took off and
played it was super great can't wait for
you guys to see it looks like yes you're
gonna be seeing a ton of celebrities
showing America that hummus can be used
with a lot of things besides just
carrots and pita okay pretzels broccoli
cereal ice cream this is absolutely the
housewives who haven't been seen
together for years on TV so that's gonna
cause that fan base a little ruckus
[Music]
let's go bro I'm doing real well we're
good real well a little bit of word of a
success anything talk about it say
something about it it's all patience bro
patience everybody just wants it to fast
right that's what [ __ ] up every single
person if they just slowed it down and
didn't hear any of these people it's
just [ __ ] patience
it's [ __ ] always yes sir I'm really
well bro how are you good
one of the better creative minds in the
world that we were just talking about
started [ __ ] Geoffrey the very famous in
ceramic out but beyond that talent for
the real world can you see my post where
I held up a sign and it said something
did you see that on Instagram oh that
was a nod to what they did they created
account you notice how I never tagged
anybody but I tagged in my post who
would sign listen to me I'm telling you
I know this world you know I know
there's very few people I give credit to
because it's a hard game that we play he
knows so we got to save my life to me
i'ma tell you right now you fail it's
good to see you too Brown doing well my
partner Ryan are you doing well you
remember you remembered me right now I
gonna see bro I love when people come up
to you and ask you like go what are you
doing
so I'm here performing here tonight at
night I know that and then I'm here
launching
hello you in the hotel bar I'm here
because we have an event with Dwayne
Wade the karaoke thing from 6 to 9 today
in four years can you and join me come
and see me and J Balvin product that
we're launching right after you know
anytime anytime I'm here I'm here until
6:00 I don't have a new one you got it
because you've hit me up the other day
let me see if I uh we are prepping for
the big event
the 137 karaoke event with Dwayne Wade
super excited right now we're shooting
some influencer stuff and different
campaign work on the 137 side and
everyone's prepping for a couple hours
from now on the actual event I'll be
judging if you know anything about my
judging capabilities I will not be
pushed over by the talent I don't care
how much I like them as a human I don't
care how much the crowd likes them I
will be making my [ __ ] judgment on
their talents on the yogi
[Music]
I have a bad feeling about this give a
jet stat let's [ __ ] go
notice how I knew exactly what it was
going to show me I [ __ ] got low heat
well dr. J what I gotta put this in the
office don't direct me here and talented
that's a good situation I mean I know I
mean it's definitely unplug so you can
oh I thought your favorite meme was when
Dustin's always got technical
difficulties and were always four
minutes behind on the podcast Dustin I
know you made a big appearance for being
super attractive on episode 1 or 2 but
this [ __ ] [ __ ] has got to get tight I
swallow every piece of gum I've
swallowed every piece of gum that I've
ever seen in my life
nobody and I mean nobody blog it takes
better baths and Sylvie's than me blog
if you think I knew that
El Paso si to tell you or 9 hours apart
you're nuts there were super close
sorry guys no problem how are you how's
your run going good I do it I'm one of
the hey maybe I did change my life
thank you she's pumped shoot yes sir you
do I'm Gary
nice to meet you me Thank You ban you do
you looking at answer are you you do
just a good answer
do you want to be on video are you
interested in be on video sir okay have
a good day may say we work on a team
where we create videos Janet I closed it
out
he does like motivational stuff oh god I
see a man I'm gonna approach him
[Music]
no he's walking away he's moving way too
fast
follow him follow him
[Music]
all right okay he's moving away excuse
me do you have one second yeah one
second or are you okay didn't work it's
not working this ain't working
now I can now I'm finally seeing how
harsh New Yorkers are I'm not interested
but rejection these guys let's go
outside
oh my god so cold oh I feel I my bones
do you know Gary Vee we're going on the
trip
very rocket ship oh no he's walking oh
he got long legs oh no he's going fast
okay can't catch up damn it Gary you got
seven point six million almost eight
million followers and none of them are
here what the then why don't we just do
a little office with everyone
dan they're just gonna keep walking
we're doing fine well people that like
just wanna be on cam are we not
approaching them the right way don't be
suspicious don't be suspicious maybe
we're just not doing it right maybe
maybe we secretly filmed them okay never
move it
maybe how much we got like six homies
now that's nice
[Music]
hard work pays off do not look at it
look I'm going over there later okay I'm
gonna go get lunch
how are you guys doing over here sailing
[Music]